Alexandra Ocasio Cortez responds to my
invitation to discuss and debate it
doesn't go well president Trump
announced his sprint is fourth and we'll
check the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
well it's busy day yesterday we have a
lot to get to today so we'll jump right
into it in just a second first I wanna
remind you that you need to be
constantly updating your resume you need
to be constantly adding new skills to
your package of skills that you can then
market to your employers and that is why
there is skill share skill share is an
online learning platform with over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
and everything from illustration to data
science from mobile photography to
creative writing you name it they've got
experts teaching it to you these are 45
minute classes taught by people who know
what they are doing whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set or start a side hustle or just
explore a new passion that's what skills
share is there to do we here at the
office of taking a bunch of Skillshare
classes I've taken ones in social media
marketing and watercolors believe it or
not they've got classes on legitimately
everything and they are taught by people
who really know what they are doing go
check it out right now join the millions
of students are already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
skills share for just 99 cents that's
right skill share is offering Ben
Shapiro show listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro again that
skill shared comm slash Shapiro to start
your two months right now that skill
shared comm slash apparel go check it
out right now it's the best way in the
really on the Internet to make your
skill set better skills share calm use
that slash up hero and get two months
for just 99 cents okay so as you know
over the last couple of days I've been
offering Alexandra Ocasio quartz has the
Democratic darling the future of the
Democratic Party according to Tom Perez
the media hits media sensation I've
offered her to come on the Sunday
special and have a one-hour discussion I
offered to have a debate with her I
offered to give $10,000 to her campaign
obviously that was somewhat facetious
considering that I think was what the
election limit like 7,500 bucks
something like that in any case I'm not
looking to violate the law I also
offered to give that money to charity or
to raise money to charity and she didn't
respond which is her prerogative she
doesn't have to respond I mean that's
that's her thing fine
yeah and she had essentially called
Allie Stuckey and a bunch of
conservatives cowards for not wanting to
have discussions with her and instead
creating satire of her so I figured okay
we'll open her an open forum for her to
come on the sunday special and all
legitimate ly have anyone from the left
on the Sunday special one of the
funniest things about this is that
effort after I offered Ocasio Cortes to
come on the show a bunch of leftists who
are
pretty prominent start emailing me
saying well why don't you invite me and
it's like okay fine that's great
like I'd prefer to have more people on
the Sunday special with whom I can have
intelligent conversations from the left
like let's talk about Norway let's talk
about Denmark let's talk about socialism
let's talk about what socialist and what
isn't let's do all those things I don't
care like that's that's what I thought
this whole debate this whole area of
American life was supposed to be about I
enjoy those conversations well Alexandre
Ocasio Cortez took this the wrong way
she took this the wrong way and instead
here is what she tweeted out in response
to my invitation quote just like cat
calling I don't owe her response to
unsolicited requests from men with bad
intentions and also like cat calling for
some reason they feel entitled to one
well and feel entitled to response you
don't have to respond we can write about
it if you don't respond considering that
you've called bunch of people on the
right cowards for not supposedly taking
on your ideas but I'm very confused as
to what cat calling is like in Queens I
just want to like hone in on this for
just a second how does this go in Queens
is this really like construction worker
in Queens like hey girl let's have a one
hour conversation on trade policy
deficits and fiscal responsibility in
Nordic nations baby come on come on
downtown public conversation and I'll
give you ten thousand dollars to your
favorite charity if we can have a public
debate on why neo-marxist thought lacks
as compared to the Vienna School of
Economics hmm that's how it goes in
Queens catcalling is real weird in
Queens got to tell you but I do love the
fact that her in like there's so many
responses she could have given that are
better than this I mean not to advise
her political team but there are a lot
of things you could have done here you
could have just said nah not interested
or you know what you're not running for
office I'm not gonna debate with
somebody who's not running for office or
you know they're better interviews that
I can do that reach out to my core
constituency they're they're like a
thousand better responses then this is
just like catcalling also have you met
me have you seen me do I seem like the
kind of guy who catcalls ladies I'm in
Orthodox Jew who was a virgin until I
was married I've never catcalled anyone
in any context ever legitimately my cat
calls to my wife involve me like
yesterday I can't called my
I will admit I can't call my wife
yesterday we were driving and we happen
to be next to each other in our cars and
she rolled down her window and I
whistled at her she took it she took
deep offense at this we are now getting
divorced because of cat calling but like
what like this is this is what cat
calling is now so I do love the fact
that the entire left resonated to this
so the entire left decided that she is a
heroine for playing victim for having
someone request a discussion or debate
with her and again the discussions we do
on the Sunday special the reason I
offered either a discussion or a debate
is because these are two separate things
right we can have a full-on moderated
debate like I did with Chang tiger we
can have a full-on moderated debate like
I've done multiple times all across the
country with various people on the other
side or we can have an open discussion
which I've also done right we had Sam
Harris who's a who's in militant atheist
I disagree with him on a lot of things
we had him on for an hour we at Eric
Weinstein on Eric is a dude who is of
the left when it comes to economics
right I'm on for a full hour and just
discuss this stuff I'm fully willing to
go back and forth so if she just wanted
to come on and have like a cordial
conversation that was unmoderated and i
would just ask her questions and let her
talk that's what the sunday special is
so i offered both empathy in the entire
left responded as though I had done
something deeply deeply wrong and how
dare I offer to give money to a charity
or to our campaign in order to
incentivize her to have a conversation
about economics it's just like cat
calling it's just like sexism it is
amazing how fast they runs their
intersectional cubbyholes when things
get a little bit a little bit dicey oh
well he must be doing that because she's
a woman are you kidding me how many
times on this program have I suggested
that I would debate Bernie Sanders
anywhere anytime I've done it so many
times I can't even tell you right like
I'm said I would like to debate
Elizabeth Warren I said I would like to
debate Bernie Sanders I've said I would
like to debate Alexander Ocasio cortes
I'm happily willing to discuss with a
variety of folks who are on the other
side of the aisle like and this is I've
always been like this right I just enjoy
doing this stuff hey I got a law-school
recommendation when I was at Harvard
I got a law school recommendation from
Melania Guinier Lani Guinier was one of
my press professors there she is a
socialist she's a Green Party socialist
Lani Guinier is so far to the left when
Bill Clinton tried to appoint her under
Sepp
pterri of labour in his administration a
Democratic Senate turned her down she's
that far to the left the differences
lani actually likes talking about issues
professor Guinier had a good time with
me in the class but apparently this is
forbidden now if you ask anybody who
doesn't want a debate to debate and it
happens to be a woman then it's it's
sexist cat calling again cat calling is
real weird
over in Queens I just I don't understand
it also I like the fact that she puts
all this emphasis on he's a man with bad
intentions what what are my bad
intentions exactly to make you look dumb
well only you can make you look dumb
okay really only you we can do it live
only you can make yourself look bad in a
political debate plus it wouldn't matter
anyway let's be real about this if she
didn't abate with me the entire left
would declare she won no matter what she
did it doesn't matter anyway
okay but I'm a man with bad intentions
first of all how dare she assume my
gender second of all like really I have
bad intentions yes the yes
the cleanest cut guy when it comes to
sexual relations in all of human history
yeah I yes that that clearly you've
nailed it you've nailed it so here is my
response on Twitter so I responded this
way discussion and debate are not bad
intentions slandering someone as a
sexist cat caller without reason or
evidence does demonstrate both cowardice
and bad intent however which seems mild
to me it seems like a mild response and
then I followed that up with this it but
sure go with the Orthodox Jew who has
never cat called a woman in his life
he's actually a sexist cat caller for
asking for a discussion or debate I'm
sure your media stick offense will eat
it up and eat it up they did because the
crown must be protected protect
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez from her own
incapacity to actually hold the
conversation with somebody on the other
side she can barely hold the
conversation apparently with Chris Cuomo
I mean she literally suggested a day and
a half ago that Medicare would pay for
people's funerals or something and she
was unable to answer a basic question
Matt how she pay for her jinan pod save
America so I'm I can't say I'm supremely
surprised about all of this but the left
attempt to defend her is truly
astonishing
so Vox is writing something about this
and there I'm the bad guy right for
having requested the debate or the
discussion I'm the bad guy
and obviously I'm the bad guy because I
offer $10,000 in violation of campaign
finance law yeah guys that's
I'm gonna go to jail to debate Alexander
Ocasio Cortez that's my thing I'm
desperate to give above the legal limit
to a Democratic Socialist or
alternatively I just named a figure that
was at the top of my head without
thinking about campaign finance law you
decide which one you decide I'll also
note it's it's just it's so funny i
explicit again I explicitly offered her
to come on a discussion it's type for
him order to do a public debate type for
him and this is the worst thing in the
world and folks on the Left were like
why would you possibly offer her that
because I offer everyone that okay
somebody from Vox wrote me and they were
like why would you offer that I don't
know because I've offered as reclined to
come on the show right the head of Vox
I've offered Jane Koston with whom I am
friends and who is very much on the left
when it comes to a wide variety of
issues she's sort of libertarian on
social issues but she's mortal and some
economic issues but she's sort of more
to the left she's a left-leaning
libertarian I think would be fair to say
I've offered her to come on the show
right I don't care I like having people
who don't share my viewpoint so that we
can at least clarify what we think about
various issues and offer data to support
those various positions why would and
they're asking like why would you invite
her she's just a candidate from Queens
Yeah right guys that's I'm inviting her
because I invite every candidate from
Queens I invited her because you called
her the future of your party I invited
her because you're the ones who
suggested that she was the wave of the
Democratic Party she was gonna be the
new leader in the Democratic Party
I didn't appoint her you did that makes
her a prominent figure in American
politics on the cover of magazines for
winning 17,000 votes in a primary you
elevated her so is it weird that I would
want to have her on look I wouldn't want
to have on some obscure senator from
Vermont either except the Democrats
decided to make him a thought leader
after him spending his entire life doing
nothing abuse the only reason I wanted
to make Bernie Sanders is because you
guys made him famous so it's all it's
all very very weird she's also never had
a cross partisan discussion which I
thought might be useful but apparently
we are not we're not going to do that so
that's that's just spectacular
again the intersectional response is
pretty amazing I'll show you how the
media responded to all of this in just a
second because it is perfectly
predictable perfectly predictable but
first let's talk about your impending
death the fact is you're gonna plot when
you do plots you want to make sure that
your funeral is actually paid for not by
Medicare you want to make sure that your
family actually
has the money than it needs if God
forbid something should happen to you
and that's why you need policy genius
life insurance is really important it's
also pretty confusing which is why four
out of ten people don't have it probably
or at least possibly you're one of those
people but if anything were to happen
you need a life insurance policy and the
best place to work through that whole
situation is policy genius.com it's the
easy way to compare life insurance
online in just five minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find the best policy for you and when
you compare quotes you save money it is
indeed that simple policy genius has
helped over 4 million people shop for
insurance they placed over 20 billion
dollars in coverage and they don't just
make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you've been putting off
getting life insurance there's no reason
to put it off any longer go to policy
genius com get some quotes apply in
minutes it's that easy you could do it
right now and you should because rates
are their lowest in 20 years policy
genius it's the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance go check it out
policy genius.com okay so here's how the
media responded to this suggestion that
I am some how analogous to a sexist
catcaller by the way isn't that sort of
demeaning to women who have actually
bends catcalled in sexist fashion like a
woman who gets whistled on the street or
some guy says something vulgar her on
the street that's the same thing as
somebody saying why don't we have a
moderated debate or a discussion about
the basic principles of economics
exactly the same single Jeep here who
legitimately has his head so far up his
took us that he can now see his colon he
tweeted out a OC that'd be Alexandra
Ocasio Curtis is really good at
responding to bad faith right-wing
rhetoric it's something I hope other
Dems can learn from ok I just like to
point out this term bad faith so folks
on the Left if they don't want to do
something they immediately just throw
out that term bad faith as those
sincerity is a measure of quality as
though if you are really sincere about
something it means more than if it's bad
faith so in other words they said this
about Sarah's young they said the people
who are upset about Sarah's young they
were upset about her in bad faith you
know as opposed to when people are truly
upset about say Kevin Williamson that
wasn't bad faith opposition to Kevin
Williamson
that was sincere opposition to Kevin
Williamson but all the people pointing
out the double standard that was bad
faith okay it's pretty easy to sling
around accusations like bad faith and
throw intent into the mix here's my rule
about to mate
if you cannot win on the facts you went
on the intent
right and this is what the left does so
frequently and I find it highly
irritating highly annoying the
suggestion is that it is a bad faith
effort to have a discussion if you just
don't want a debate because if you
assume that my intents are good my
intention is good then you might have to
treat me like a human being right this
is exactly what happened with the mark
Duplass scenario that director actor who
tweeted out that I was a good person or
a nice guy who had good intentions right
and the entire left went nuts because I
can't have good intentions I'm a bad guy
so this is how the left responds to this
they have to somehow defend the idiocy
of suggesting that a debate invitation
is now the same thing as cat calling so
it's that my I have bad faith Margaret
Sullavan who's the media columnist for
The Washington Post sweet out preach
Ocasio Cortes Ocasio 2018 preach
she's the media columnist for The
Washington Post encouraging a politician
to turn down an interview with the media
member because she likes the politician
she's the media columnist encouraging
this somehow I highly highly doubt that
where the politics reversed Margaret
Sullavan would be saying preach that if
for example Schenk Uyghur or somebody on
MSNBC right Chris Hayes invited on Sarah
Palin and Sarah Palin said this is just
like cat calling I really really doubt
that Margaret Sullavan would be saying
preach it just preach it and there's Dan
Errol who's just a socialist dolt he
says also a good rule not to debate
fascists just destroy them what is that
supposed to mean like first of all I'm
the fascist you know the guy who calls
for almost zero government intervention
and anything I'm the fascist but you
shouldn't debate them you shouldn't have
a conversation
the genius Don Moynihan is another one
of these folks he's a writer for some
obscure publication he says the debate
is officially over and we have a winner
oh good so just shouting sexist at the
ceiling is makes you a winner that's
that's terrific
that's terrific so as I suggested
shouting sexist at the moon and when you
all sorts of accolades on the left and
this is why the left is a giant fail
this is why the radical left that has
been sucked into intersectionality
they're failing with the American people
they're failing what the American people
specifically because they won't even
have conversations if I'm outside the
Overton Window pretty much everyone is
like name somebody on the right that you
think Oh Cosmo Cortez should have a
conversation with other than David from
Matt's boot or Anna Navarro
none of the three are actually on the
right at this point name one person the
answer is the left can't
well--that's can okay meanwhile the
President of the United States has
announced space force so everybody is
very excited because of space force and
it's easy to mock space force because of
the name of it right as opposed to as
opposed to you know the the space
Defense agency or something calling it's
space for sounds a lot like it's a
sci-fi it's like air force but space
force but it sounds more like a sci-fi
video game than anything else but do we
need something like this yes so Mike
Pence the vice president's of the United
States he announced what space force
would be yesterday as president Trump
has said in his words it is not enough
to merely have an American presence in
space we must have American dominance in
space and so we will and that's
precisely why we're beginning the
process of establishing a space force as
the six branch of our armed forces just
as in the past when we created the air
force establishing the space force is an
idea whose time has come
okay so he's writing about all of this
Brady this is also this is also very
good stuff and President Trump of course
in his own inimitable style tweeted this
out and he tweeted out space force all
the way space force all the way okay so
you gotta love that I mean just because
the wild enthusiasm is is always
delicious no Rothman who is certainly no
friend to the Trump administration or
the President Trump he has an entire
piece talking about why this is useful
he says though you would not know it
from those who spent the day chuckling
to themselves over the prospect of an
American Space Command the
militarization of the strategically
vital region is decades old thousands of
both civilian and military
communications and navigation satellites
operate in Earth orbit to say nothing of
the occasional human it's impossible to
say how many weapons are already
stationed in orbit because many of these
platforms are dual use meaning they
could be transformed into kill vehicles
in a moment's notice
American military planners have been
preoccupied with the preservation of
critical US communications
infrastructure in space since at least
2007 when China stunned observers by
launching a missile that intercepted and
destroyed a satellite creating thousands
of pieces of debris hurtling around the
earth at speeds faster than any bullet
America's chief strategic competitors
Russia and China rogue actors like Iran
in North Korea are all committed to
developing the capability to target
America's command and control
infrastructure a lot of which is
space-based Trump's Director of National
Intelligence Stan Coates testified in
2017 that both Moscow and Beijing are
considered attacks against satellite
systems as part of their future warfare
doctrine and are developing the
requisite anti satellite technology
those who oppose the creation of a space
branch object on a variety of ground
some of the merit more attention than
others the contention that a sixth
military branch is a redundant waste of
taxpayer money is more salient criticism
than cynical claims that Trump is
interested only in a glory project
Secretary of Defense mattis says that we
do require some sort of extension into
space although he opposes the creation
of a new of a new military service but
this idea that we don't need any sort of
encroachment into space is obviously
silly but that's not gonna stop people
on the left from mocking President Trump
over all this so Stephen Colbert decides
to mock space for us because Trump is
doing if it were Obama then it would be
a forward-thinking project obviously go
give the Astro Kaiser hell because
tonight there's big news about
[Applause]
longtime viewers of the Trump
administration will remember that
spaceforce is the president's boldest
idea that he got from a buzz lightyear
Happy Meal toy we already have NASA we
don't need space force please wait until
NASA finds life before you try to kill
it okay said silly obviously the point
of space forces to defend us from all
sorts of threats foreign and domestic
that could use space as a sort of
platform for it but it's easy to mock
space force again because of the name
and it's just a monster of the fact that
anything Trump does is going to be seen
as terrible and horrible in every
particular way that's just something
that he is his you know fond of pushing
Colbert and you see the same thing from
Scott Kelly who is a former astronaut
and he also suggests that space forces
is a bad idea I don't know a lot about
the the president's motivations on this
there don't doesn't seem to be a lot of
support out there and being a person
that spent 25 years in the military 20
of it at NASA
I never heard people really talking
about a need for a sixth branch of the
Armed Forces okay so yeah again if the
argument is sort of bureaucratic we're
done then see that's at least a better
argument but if the argument is we don't
need anything in space because Trump
then it just demonstrates full scale how
many folks on the Left seem obsessed
with with smacking Trump no matter what
the cost and it doesn't matter whether
we are more or less secure because of
any of that stuff because we do in fact
need some sort of military presence in
space this is nothing new we've been
pursuing this for quite a while okay in
just a second I want to talk about the
left sudden obsession with white
nationalism first let's talk about what
you're eating so you're at home and
you're thinking I can order out sure you
can
it'll be expensive and it probably won't
be all that healthy sometimes not even
that great tasting or you could have the
you go to the grocery store pick up all
the ingredients try to figure out a
recipe and that'll take it forever or
the best option is that you go over to
blue apron and you subscribe the reason
the blue apron is great is because they
provide you quick and easy recipe
options perfectly portioned ingredients
delivered right to your door so they
give you the recipe they give you the
everything is pre-selected for you and
then you basically just cook according
to their specifications
you've made gourmet meals they make
dinner quick easy and insanely tasty you
skip meal plan and get straight to
cooking with blue apron experience the
joy of summer with their favorite
grilling recipes they've got seasonally
inspired ingredients mouth-watering
grilling options for summer chicken with
barbecue sauce and juicy cheese burgers
with spicy slaw check out this week's
menu get your first three meals for free
at blue apron comm slash Shapiro that's
blue apron comm slash up here to get
those first three meals for free blue
apron is indeed a better way to cook and
I mean these meals look fantastic meals
like seared chicken and tangy barbecue
sauce and this stuff looks like he got
it at a restaurant but you're making it
with your family it's a blast and it
isn't that expensive and it's great go
check it out blue aprons comm slash
compare to get those first three meals
for free blue apron comm slash Shapiro
okay so something I've noticed over the
past few days is the media is suddenly
obsessed with white nationalism again
now the reason for that is because
there's gonna be another unites the
right rally which is basically a white
supremacist rally led by idiots like
Jason Kessler who are intent on saving
the country for the white people okay
now this sort of stupidity is indeed the
highest form of stupidity it's amazing
that all of the people who are
constantly talking about how white
people are somehow supreme are the
dumbest people on planet earth like it
is it is amazing to see the crossover
between stupid people and white
nationalism but in any case the media
have decided to provide outside this
outsized attention for this group of
people why because they want to suggest
that President Trump is the great
embolden er of these folks now has
president Trump emboldened these groups
these alright groups in the past he did
so in the 2016 campaign I was
extraordinarily critical of him at that
time he did so I think in
charlottesville I was extraordinarily
critical of him at the time however why
is the media now attempting to elevate a
bunch of coops and fringe coops who have
no real relevance to American politics
to a position of prominence the answer
is because they would like to paint with
a broad brush and suggest that deep down
most Trump supporters are just like the
neo-nazis who happen to be open enough
with their perspective the reason I say
this is because I was at the gym
yesterday and CNN was on the TVs
unfortunately and they were showing a
full like 5-6 minute clip of this what
literally one neo-nazi in a random town
in Pennsylvania it's a town of like 650
people and there's one neo-nazi guy
there and they
a six-minute story on this guy because
he says he likes Trump and he flies a
swastika over his house and my question
is you know how many insane people out
there are in the United States you know
many crazy people who believe crazy
things there are in the United States I
don't remember the media being intent on
tracking down members of the new Black
Panthers and asking them on national
television what they thought of Barack
Obama and whether they felt emboldened
by the Obama administration or the
holder goj I don't remember that at all
but they're doing this now on CNN like
devoting full minutes of time to people
who are obviously insane here is what it
sounded like on CNN yesterday
are you a neo-nazi do I embrace it I
don't try to push it away well you're
wearing a swastika on you sir exactly
rural America spoke up when they elected
Trump rural America and by rural America
he means white America we're staring
down the barrel of a gun here in white
America okay and then what's what's
hilarious about this is that the
interviewer says you know and then at a
certain point he became unfriendly and
started screaming at people and it was
like right because he's a crazy person
is a crazy person so he went out in the
middle of nowhere you found a crazy
person and then you said this guy is
somehow representative of a broad swath
of public opinion and we're seeing this
more and more like NPR did a full
interview with Jason Kessler again it
unites the right and Jason Kessler you
know it was giving his listing of IQ
studies on on various races now you know
discussion of race and IQ is always very
fraught but it isn't particularly
fraught when you're talking about white
nationalists who are using a claim of
race superiority in order to suggest
then we ought not allow legal immigrants
into the country or that we ought to
discriminate against particular groups
in the United States it's really gross
and the fact that these people are being
elevated is indeed I think a purposeful
project of a lot of people in the media
particularly and so they have on Jason
Kessler for like an hour the read now
people I'm left were like why are you
having on Jason Kessler you're just
elevating his view the reason NPR is
having on Jason Kessler is to suggest
the Jason Kessler again is
representative of a broad swath of
public opinion when no one knew who
Jason Kessler was until five minutes ago
and that's because the media decided to
cover him in outside stretches it's
pretty astonishing the level of double
standard in the media when it comes to
covering this kind of stuff is pretty
insane the best example of that that I
can think of happened actually
yesterday
so yesterday there was a story from
their times there's a writer named
Elizabeth Williamson she's a features
writer of in the New York Times and she
tweeted out an article from New York
Times writer Brett Stevens about Sara
Zhang remember Sara's Jean over the past
couple weeks joined the New York Times
editorial board and then it turns out
she has dozens of anti-white tweets that
have been put out over the course of
years and this writer tweeted out
welcome Sara to The Times I look forward
to reading you with interest
irrespective of agreement I trust you'll
extend the same good faith to all of
your new colleagues only through such
faith to the people institutions and
nations thrive that Stevens's op-ed and
here is what she tweeted she tweeted
here's Brett Stevens offering a classy
welcome to a colleague who has yet to
prove she deserves one OK which seems
fairly reasonable she was forced to
apologize for that so we now live in a
universe where actual anti-white racist
tweets from Sara Zhang are defended by
the mainstream media at the same time
they elevate actual racists yell white
supremacist in order to proclaim that's
the right but the left it's defending
anti-white racism is not racist in any
way and they forced this lady to
apologize for tweeting something miles
so Sarah Jang still has not issued a
real public apology for any of this
stuff she kind of got a half-hearted
apology saying she was taken out of
context and all this sort of nonsense
which she pretty much was not and yet
who was forced to apologize well
Elizabeth Williamson this features
writer was forced to apologize because
of course Elizabeth Williamson is the
bad guy
Elizabeth Williamson is the bad guy for
having suggested that Sarah Zhang has
failed to live up to her her own
standards with regard to racism and
people wonder why we don't take the
media seriously enough this is the
reason why we don't take the media
seriously enough this is the reason why
we don't take the media seriously enough
so there is that it's just it's an
amazing thing it's an amazing thing okay
so I want to get to the mailbag and we
will do so in just a second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire calm
and subscribe so for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily wire
calm when you do you the rest of this
show live you get the rest of the
Michael mostra live again thrust in the
Andrew Klavan show live you also get to
be part of our mailbag which we are
doing right now so if you subscribe now
you get to ask me live questions in the
mailbag I feel that you will enjoy this
experience also with the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels $99 you get
the leftist here's hot or cold tumbler
that comes along with
all of the wonders of the universe so go
check that out also when you subscribe
at YouTube or iTunes then you get access
to our Sunday special we have on a wide
variety of guests sadly not including
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez but everyone
else will come on and we'll have great
discussions about a variety of issues
give you more information and more data
it's a lot of fun go check it out please
subscribe we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right so let's jump into the mailman
let's do an extra extra large segments
of the mailbag today so a guy who calls
himself Jason Tesla writes dear mr.
Shapiro I'm asking this question since
you were a lawyer today another major
March in Charlottesville is taking place
led by the notorious Jason Kessler live
15 minutes outside the city and my name
also happens to be Jason Kessler
my brother has a very difficult time at
work as his co-workers refuse to believe
that the man is not his brother and I've
dealt with a lot of whispers and
questions around my own job because of
this do you think as a lawyer I have a
path to legal action against this
absolute piece of human garbage people
have confused me with him for almost 15
years it was just as bad when he was
writing articles in the daily progress
demanding universal health care I didn't
like pro Obama Pro socialism Jason
Kessler I certainly don't like the swing
to Hitler - Jason Kessler you don't have
a legal case unfortunately against a
dude before his name that's just it's
really unfortunate there are a lot of
people who there was a commercial at one
point where a guy would go out and like
meet Michael Jordan and Michael Jordan
was just some guy who was living the
middle of Ohio for him for a long time
you could actually did that I remember
there was a a guy who went out got
blurbs on the back of his books from
various characters who had the same
names as famous people said go out and
find some guy named Warren Buffett who
was actually just in a trailer park and
in Indiana and then they get him to
endorse the book and then they say
Warren Buffett endorsed the book so
unfortunately crossover when it comes to
naming is nothing you can do anything
about legally and that's just that's sad
Mac says hello Ben what are your
thoughts on Benjamin Powell's and other
economist thoughts that open borders
would lead to a 150 percent growth in
GDP if that's true don't you think that
would offset any other problems that
could arise with mass immigration thank
you love the show well I do think that
you would see a rise in GDP if you are
economically free free movement of labor
and free movement of people is good for
economies because you can get lower
priced labor because you get better
skills because free markets make things
cheaper and better at the same time now
are there other countervailing concerns
we have to worry about sure we have to
worry about safety concerns when it
comes to free movement of Labor just
because people are moving across borders
doesn't mean they should necessarily
vote in our elections this is why guest
worker programs I don't really have a
problem with there are a lot of folks
who are deeply afraid of bringing labor
into the United States guest worker
programs and such people with green
cards I've always been a big advocate of
free movement of labor across borders
that is not the same
thing as free movement of people without
checking their security backgrounds and
there are a lot of folks who are scared
that if you are actually opening your
borders with regard to labor that's
gonna throw Americans out of jobs the
answer to that is if you are not
competitive on the global labor scale
you're probably going to be out of a job
anyway as corporations move out overseas
in order to accommodate cheaper labor
and cheaper wages overseas as well this
is why there's been an attempt to sort
of claw back revenue from those
companies and punish those companies for
offshoring but the reality is that so
long as America remains a free and open
economy there will be a lot of
investment I agree that free movement of
labor increases GDP and also I don't
believe that if you come here to work
you should be on welfare right if you're
coming here to work then you should be
here to work you shouldn't be on our
welfare system that is a drain on public
resources to which presumably you learn
many ways not paying in except for maybe
sales tax now Christopher says hey Ben
what is the difference between the
liberty and right to privacy would this
be similar to the concept the
government's protect Liberty but your
community controls what you do in
private well Liberty does have a certain
element of a right to privacy the
problem is the right to privacy has been
Mis defined by the courts to mean pretty
much anything they wanted to mean so you
have a right to privacy and that means
that you can do an inherently non
private act driving to a doctor and
having a medical procedure done that has
inherently not in act in accordance with
privacy however Liberty does mean that
you get to do what you want so long as
you're not hurting another person and so
long as you're not hurting anyone else
you get to wave your fist around that to
me is the basic definition of Liberty
that of course is not my definition
that's John Stuart Mill's definition of
Liberty and I think that that is
essentially correct when it comes to
government intervention now how should
you use Liberty you should use Liberty
to cultivate your own virtue to
cultivate reason it's called to be a
good argumentation the invasion of
people's Liberty on behalf of the great
collective is a tremendous danger it's a
tremendous danger in people who cite you
know the Nordic countries invading
Liberty in order to provide social
safety nets this is not to say that you
can't do that it is to say that that is
in fact an invasion of Liberty they're
taking my money to redistribute it to
someone else is an invasion of my rights
but it's the MIS definition of right to
privacy that I find problematic very
often when we have these discussions the
unfortunate thing is that there there
are folks who will vaguely define a term
and then ask you whether you agree with
that they'll say do you believe in the
right to privacy and you're like yeah I
kind of like the right to privacy and
like well I mean abortion say well
that's not
I meant you kind of have to define your
terms before you have these discussions
Cody says hi Ben
I just want to start by saying I'm a
huge fan of you and your show I have a
friend named London who's also a big fan
say hi to him for me
I have interesting discussions with
about Israel and Palestine we're both
pro-israel but he feels Israel's
committed some serious unjustified
atrocities against the Palestinians such
as the Palestinian Exodus of 1948 I feel
this particular atrocity is
misrepresentative but we would like to
hear your opinion on it in addition to
that you feel Israel has committed any
atrocities against the Palestinians that
were unjustified if so has Israel made
up for it and or at least attempted to
make up for it in any way thanks Cody so
sure I mean in any war there are
atrocities day dariya scene is obviously
the most obvious example of an atrocity
that happened during the 1948 war for
independence but the idea that Israel
forcibly expelled hundreds of thousands
of Palestinians is simply not true what
happened is that there was an invasion
by Jordan by Egypt by Syria in 1948 in
Saudi Arabia as well and Imams were
literally preaching over the radio like
leaders were preaching over to the radio
that that Arabs should get out of the
way of the onrushing
Arab troops that they wouldn't be heard
and Israel was begging people dropping
leaflets asking people to stay write the
Declaration of Independence for Israel
explicitly asks the Arab populations
that are living in the area to stay
within Israel and obviously a lot of
those people fled it is it is
fascinating to note that at the same
exact time that hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians left this area because
there are countries were asking them to
leave the area and there a bunch of
great books on this that at the exact
same time hundreds of thousands of Jews
were expelled forcibly expelled from
countries all around the Middle East
Israel took all of the men and they
became citizens none of the Palestinians
who were quote-unquote
expelled but many of whom actually fled
a huge percentage from actually fled
none of them were made citizens of these
Arab countries instead they're kept in
refugee camps for use in public
relations against as a club against
Israel there's a great book called from
time immemorial by Joe and Peter
specifically about this issues like a
four hundred and fifty page heavily
researched tome on this particular issue
Tim says hey Ben huge huge fan of the
show in the past couple of months have
been taking steps from preparing to
propose to my girlfriend asking her
parents buying the ring et cetera well
it's a very exciting time and I have no
doubts about taking that step this
prospect of marriage remains to welcome
a daunting challenge as young aspiring
medical professional I also know there
will be challenges a lot of time and
effort sufficiently to both
my career and love my future wife that
she deserves I know your wife is a
doctor you're obviously a lawyer so I
know you've already walked this kind of
path in many ways any advice for a young
man seeking to excel both maritally and
professionally thanks so much yes
marital peace is more important than
professional peace that you you do have
to put your spouse first but you and
your spouse have to know what kind of
road is coming and it is brutal like I'm
by this point I'm just so annoyed with
my wife's medical education I can't even
tell you I can't wait until she's done
literally since we've been dating she's
been on this path we've now been married
for ten years and we've been we've known
each other for 11 and she's been in
medical school in residency working for
a lab or in college that entire time
that that is a long long road but the
idea that you can have everything is not
true you just have to understand that
both of you have to be giving right that
it is her job to be giving toward you
and it is your job to be giving toward
her sometimes that means you have to
drop off dinner at the office and you
have to take off and as much as you hate
that that's just the way it's gonna go
expectations are the killers of
marriages you expect things from your
spouse and those things don't
materialize and then you're mad you're
angry expectations and marriage should
be low giving should be high if your
expectations are low but your giving is
high you're gonna have a great marriage
if your expectations are high but your
giving is low you're gonna be divorced
in two years why it's his Haven and what
are some of the more underrated and
overrated musicals and what do you think
often makes overrated works as popular
as they are well to me the most
overrated musical of the modern era is
Hamilton I know people love Hamilton
I've discussed this on the show before I
don't think it's bad I just am NOT a fan
of the type of music and I think that
these supposed brilliance of the lyrics
is overrated to me specifically because
great lyricism to me is about word
choice not about syllabic fit and and
they're there a lot of syllables in
Hamilton it seems easier to write patter
as as literate to me than to write a
simple lyric that chooses the correct
word this is why even with Sondheim's
work I think his lyrical work in the
song of pretty women is better than his
lyric work in some of his more kind of
pyrotechnic songs as far as other
overrated works I would say that so lame
is I've always said is highly overrated
cuz it has a couple of good songs and a
lot of fluff and the thing is 9 hours
long it is just it's just interminable I
mean it's extraordinarily long I also
thank God they've restored it for an
orchestra originally they scored for a
for a synthesizer and they need to use
pen
tones which means that you didn't even
have that tone underneath it actually
gives you a grounding for for the actual
singer to move off of its I think lame
is is highly overrated
obviously cats is overrated cuz cats is
just garbage they're a bunch of really
really overrated musicals most of them
have happened in the modern era most of
them are sort of cheap knockoffs
musicals have gotten significantly worse
in my opinion over the past 30 years at
least as high Ben when you're invited to
college campuses and events how do you
prepare for your speeches how do you
decide what to speak about and how much
of your speech is pre-written well you
know I sort of decided speak about based
on what topic I'm interested in and then
I spend a fair bit of time actually
researching the topic trying to find all
the different perspectives and trying to
see what is true and what is not so that
I know where weaknesses are in my own
arguments I would say that for every
hour that I speak I put 10 or 11 hours
into into reading and writing about a
particular issue before I speak about it
and if I don't know something I'm happy
to say that I don't know anything about
it and I'd like to research it and get
back to them Daniel says will trey gowdy
replace jeff sessions as the next
Attorney General well I'm not sure of
sessions is actually going anywhere in
the near future simply because President
Trump is afraid that it would look like
obstruction which is probably a
reasonable fear even though it's not
obstruction you can fire your attorney
general at any time I don't think Jeff
Sessions is going anywhere
Stephen says dear God Emperor Shapiro
what is a good level of government
regulation in health care my answer to
this is virtually none I don't think the
government should be deeply involved in
health care regulation I think free
markets should take priority I think
that we have a tort system for a reason
and if you do something wrong in the
medical field you can be sued into the
ground the idea that we need a
government in order to force a doctor to
care for a patient properly I just don't
find that particularly convincing I also
think that people have come to rely on
the government and think the government
is their great guarantor of safety so
there was how about the Food and Drug
Administration well you'd be eating
tainted food if not for that really
would you how many companies do you
think would be forcibly attempting to
you know poison their consumers if it
weren't for that it turns out that in an
era of particularly social media
marketing the ability to find out bad
stuff about companies has never been
higher the market takes care of a lot of
these particular issues plus you would
have private rating agencies I think the
same thing would happen in the medical
field veronica's says how do
conservative women who have prioritized
family over career go back and have a
career if I'd known that I'd be single
at this age I'd have just gone for the
money
the first place well you know I I've
always advocated for women to have the
credentials to have a successful career
because I think that you should be able
to be financially independent at any
point is why I plan on sending my
daughter to college or as much education
as she wishes to engage with it's why
I've always thought that it's great that
my wife has gone through all this work
at medical school because god forbid
something should happen to me I want her
to be able to take care of herself and
take care of the kids and feel fulfilled
while doing it so I think that the way
to balance this stuff is different for
everyone but I think in a minimum you
should have the job qualifications
necessary to start working your way up
from the bottom if need be if God forbid
something happens and you're left bereft
Ryan says our insurance companies really
crooks should all insurance be nonprofit
like Ben Carson posited in 2012 no
insurance companies are not crooks
insurance companies have a profit
incentive just like every other company
and that means you really have to read
insurance contracts carefully it also
means that you should have financial
advisors who read the insurance
contracts for you if you can possibly
afford it and you should find the most
transparent insurance companies that you
can find it's just that insurance
companies with their profit incentive do
have an incentive to push against you
when you make a claim against insurance
because that's how they make their money
but they're no more crooked than any
other business that I could name profit
incentives drive hard bargains house has
been how can we fairly vet refugees when
their countries don't properly keep
records well this is a really difficult
thing right it's it's difficult to
fairly vet refugees when their countries
don't keep records but it is not our
obligation to take in refugees if we
can't vet them listen I I'm very
sympathetic to people who are trying to
flee their home countries I really am I
think that we should try to take in
people who want to come here and become
Americans and engage in the American Way
of life in the American ideology I think
all that's good but the obligation is to
prove that you're going to be a good
American citizen it's not on the
American system to prove that you're not
going to be a good American citizen I
just like you would have to file an
application to join any sort of club
well you have to file an application to
join the American club and I think that
that is all perfectly reasonable but
let's see a rights been is there any way
possible you can stop cat calling
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez I can't believe
the daily wire is about to have a me-too
moment I know I know I have to stop
offering to talk with people it's just
it's just brutal it's just terrible
Mason says hey Ben my fiance and I are
on the road to Iowa to see my
grandfather before he passes from lung
cancer he's an ex pastor
devout atheist because of the way the
church treated him you have any advice
on methods of discussion to help him see
that God does exist and loves him my new
he's very intelligent well-read and as a
Carl Sagan fan as well love your show
thank you for doing what you do you
strengthened my faith and my beliefs
unbelievable unbelievably thank you
Mason that really means a lot to me um
you know my chief argument against this
argument that churches treat people
badly and therefore God doesn't exist is
people are bad people do bad things and
to judge a the idea of a creator on the
basis of the fact that people are flawed
seems to me bad logic you can say this
about any institution any institution
they're terrible atheists there are
terrible religious people they're
terrible public schoolteachers they're
terrible priests they're terrible rabbis
there are terrible people in every walk
of life and if your allegiance to a
religion is based upon the behavior of
the people who are participants in the
religion then I think that you ought to
examine your religious beliefs a little
bit more deeply there there's a case to
be made for agnosticism or atheism but I
don't think it lies in the evils of
human beings who are going to be evil to
a certain extent regardless of what
ideology they hold the question really
is if you follow the injunctions of a
particular ideology doesn't make you
better and I think that it is very
difficult to argue that Christians who
actually abide by Christian beliefs are
not made better people by doing so as a
general rule right they're always
exceptions but as a general rule Dennis
Prager I think has a great test on this
if all you know about two people is that
one is a regular churchgoer and one is
not a regular churchgoer that's all you
know about these two people and one of
them has to babysit your child which one
are you going to pick it's a pretty good
test okay sigh as says have you ever
been to Disney World or do you only go
to Disney like yes a few years ago
before my kids were born my wife and I
did a vacation down in Orlando we went
to Disney World and it was great Disney
is a wonderful company Anthony says hey
Ben with all of the available data
proving socialism does not work how is
it that the left continues to push
socialism I think is the end of that
question the answer is that it keeps
shifting which country they're basing
socialism on so their favorite this week
is Norway which is a capitalist country
with socialist redistribution as
policies they have heavily regulations
in in areas of banking and then the real
question they have to ask is was the
prosperity of Norway based on socialism
or was it based on the capitalist
infrastructure that was built before the
advent of socialism in Norway and that's
a serious question because basically
socialism redistributes the gains and
kills the profit incentive
so it's not say that socialist
structures can't exist on top of a
capitalist growth curve but it is to say
that if you make the entire system
socialist you're likely to kill that
growth curve right that is that is the
actual argument but there's an argument
to be made that you know some socialist
redistributionist programs are effective
in achieving their results they are not
effective in achieving growth or in
achieving the best possible product at
the lowest available price that is what
socialist systems are not good for I am
says what is the legality requirements
of private companies using public
infrastructure our companies on public
lands subject to First Amendment rights
and would that not apply to Internet
companies well the idea of regulating
certain companies as public utilities
which is I think what you're asking
about here public utilities are
utilities that are required to give a
particular service for a particular
price at any at any level basically and
if there are private companies that have
a profit motive they're not run in the
same way as public utilities they're not
owned by the by the government
themselves simply being adjacent to a
road does not make you a public utility
and even using that road if you are a
trucking company does not make you a
public utility either because you're a
private company that is paying taxes for
the building of that infrastructure okay
this is the last question
let's see Daniel says hey Ben I am
excited to go to your live show next
week in Phoenix what is your opinion
regarding the Supreme Court's ruling
that states can collect sales taxes from
online retailers of thanks and shabbat
shalom so my opinion is that states
probably can collect sales taxes from
online Realty retailers is really a
jurisdictional question with the Nexus
of business is the way that it's usually
done in Civil Procedure is your business
basically doing a lot of business in the
state is it located within the state
there's sort of a balancing test that
goes on if I remember my cipro correctly
and if you are doing your business in
the state of California it seems not
unreasonable for the state of California
to charge that sales tax do I oppose the
charging of the sales tax yes because
one of the great things about living in
a country with a free and open Internet
is the fact that I don't have to pay a
sales tax on every equation however it
does give an advantage to internet
companies as opposed to brick-and-mortar
stores right that's that's the real
argument in favor of a sales tax on
Internet companies okay so will be so
you know let's do a thing I like in the
thing I hate almost forgot and then we
will be back here on Monday so things I
like so over the course of this week I
had a chance to see the new
Mission Impossible movie and it really
is a lot of fun here is what the preview
looked like of the new Mission
Impossible film the end always Finn is
coming and the blood will be on your
hand the fallout of all your good
intentions you had a terrible choice to
make in Berlin one life over millions
now the world is at risk this is the
CIA's mission if he had held on to the
plutonium we wouldn't be having this
conversation this teaser movie exists to
have a bunch of fantastic action
set-pieces
so the plot is okay the twist comes
about halfway through and it's not
really much of a twist
but and in henry cavill is predictably
kind of solid in his role I actually
like Henry Cavill better as a villain
than as a hero as a general rule just
because he is so solid and his approach
to acting and so you can you sort of
feel like maybe there's something
simmering under the surface even when
there's not so but the movies great to
look at it's got a couple of sequences
that are just fantastic it has one of
the best action sequences that I've seen
in the recent past and it's it the
entire sequence is basically Tom Cruise
running through Paris it's just great
all right but it's it's pretty it's
pretty great in terms of a popcorn flick
it is a pure popcorn flick I mean you
just go to the theater you tune out
everything and you watch a bunch of
great action scenes so it's really good
go check out Mission Impossible fallout
which is one of the better of the
Mission Impossible movies okay now let's
do a couple of things that I hate so
Chuck Schumer says that Roe vs. Wade
ought to be upheld because it's part of
the fabric of American life this is I
think a terrible terrible argument I
think what it is is people we've had Roe
for so long and it's been so much the
part and fabric of American life that
people think well no matter who's on the
court it'll pretty much stay where it is
I don't think that's accurate okay so
the idea that everything is part of the
fabric of American life and therefore
cannot change obviously did not hold
with slavery or segregation or should it
have the idea that abortion is part of
the fabric of everyday life does not
mean that you uphold a bad judicial
decision because something has become
embedded in American life if that were
the argument then you wouldn't be able
to change anything in American life
and that of course would be very very
silly hey other things that I hate so
Samantha be who again has run away with
the title of least funny human being on
on full-frontal with samantha be she had
one of her folks follow around Sean
Spicer on his book tour to sort of mock
him now I don't remember anybody in the
media doing this with regard to Ben
Rhodes
even though Ben Rhodes is as dishonest
or more dishonest than Sean Spicer in
his approach to politics but this is all
very funny funny because you're
following around a former member of the
Trump administration we've joined up on
the first leg of his book tour starting
in New York the scene was electric
I had one I had one how do you feel
about profiting off of lying to the
American public I mean you're making a
lot of money I'm just wondering how you
feel about that that evening we followed
him to another event at the Rhode Island
Country Club
[Music]
so much humor okay I'm just this is this
is the part of comedy that I hate is
that it's not comedy it's it's clapped
her right it's not it's not laughter
it's clapped her that you you clap and
then you sort of laugh because you're
clapping but nothing here is inherently
funny the comedians have decided that
all they have to do is basically shout
Trump to the moon and then everybody
will give the money and so far it's been
working out well for them and there's
this whole Netflix special and I can't
member the name of the woman who was
doing it but there are all these
articles about why she was changing the
nature of comedy by being unfunny and
the answer was that she was angry so she
was unfunny and but she was on the left
so that was good the the destruction of
comedic standards simply because he hate
President Trump is pretty dramatic and
pretty and pretty sewing yeah her name
was Ann Annette I guess right that's the
name of that that's special on Netflix
it's it's not good let's just put it
that way okay so we'll be back around
Monday with all of the latest we'll see
you then i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018